joined now by the shadow education
secretary bridget phillips and hi thanks
for joining us on the program this
morning much appreciated um
what should happen
next as far as the sugray report is
concerned should we see all of it we
should see all of it um but i don't
think we need sue gray to tell us what
is absolutely clear to the british
people which is that the prime minister
has lied and lied and lied again he's
taken us all for fools treated the
british people with complete contempt
and we have this ridiculous spectacle of
the foreign secretary and a whole litany
of senior ministers paraded out every
day to come up with ever more ridiculous
excuses for what we all knew happened
you know there's someone in the in the
shape of the foreign secretary who has
aspirations to be prime minister she has
to look herself in the eye and think
whether she really wants to continue to
prop up a prime minister who has lost
the respect of the british people lost
all my moral authority and is frankly
making us an international laughing
stock your leader did the same should he
be investigated by the police as well
there is absolutely no suggestion that
kiyostama broke any rules and it's just
ridiculous to compare the two i can tell
you what if kiyosama were prime minister
he wouldn't have been holding boozy
parties in the number 10 garden during
lockdown that is not the kind of person
that he is he would have been absolutely
focused on making sure our country got
through it not thinking that somehow he
was above the law i mean he's the former
director of public prosecutions he takes
us incredibly seriously the prime
minister however
thinks we're all born yesterday that we
can't see exactly what's gone on it is
just completely wrong it is a shameful
spectacle and now we've got the
metropolitan police investigating i mean
what on earth is going on
um given that he was former gpp then he
should have known that he shouldn't be
eating sandwiches and drinking beer
inside there is no suggestion that kia
stammer broke the rules or broke the law
it is ridiculous we weren't allowed to
do that at that time were we
you know everything that he did was in
line with the rules what we know how the
prime minister said well he did well the
prime minister concedes all of this
happened we've just had a various kind
of strange excuses as to exactly what's
going on but you know i think the
british people can see for themselves
what's happening here i think it's now
for senior conservative politicians for
the conservative party to think whether
they really want to continue to put the
country through this it's time the prime
minister just did the decent thing and
resigned they're so mired in scandal and
are making excuses for what's been going
on that they're not in a position to
tackle the cost of living crisis that
families are facing we however have got
a clear plan for how we provide support
for families with those gas and
electricity bills that are so high this
winter with you know support for every
family but extra help for those that
need it most with a windfall tax on oil
and gas providers he was accosted by
somebody with a bit of cake you know you
can't criticize him for that
i mean it's hard to know where to begin
with this litany of utterly utterly
ridiculous excuses they seem to think
the conservative party and all of these
ministers that are wheeled out every day
seem to think that we're all idiots we
can see what's going on the british
people know what has gone on it's time
the prime minister for the first time in
his life just did the decent thing and
went you're not going to not unless he's
forced to well this is why it really is
for the conservative party now to think
whether they're prepared to continue to
prop up this prime minister who we all
know has lied and lied a little bit
i mean i've had ministers on the program
over the last two days three days we saw
dominic rob in the house yesterday in
the uh central lobby lots of them are
all saying they've got um his um for
some support
well they've obviously got law of
self-respect and no respect actually for
the institutions of our country if
that's the way that they go on because
when the british people were doing what
was asked of them when children were
mainly at home when they weren't able to
go to school when nhs staff were working
in intensive care when our bus drivers
were going out to work delivery drivers
when everyone was following the rules
doing what was asked of them in the way
that we always behave in britain the
prime minister number 10
people there were wheeling in suitcases
of boost to have parties i mean it's
just complicated
we don't know yet we don't know we have
to wait for the sugar report don't we
well i don't think instead once or twice
on this show
well i think we all want to see it but
the government shouldn't seek to use sue
grey as a shield to defend what's
frankly indefensible what we can all see
for ourselves and what the british
people know to be the case but if you
ask for an investigation and that's what
you asked for then you have to wait for
the results um if it doesn't come today
probably won't come tomorrow so it could
be pushed into next week what will
labour be doing about that what would
you be saying about that well we want to
see it of course we do but what we what
we are prepared to wait well we want to
see it as soon as possible the british
people want to see it but let's not
pretend that the sue grey report is the
answer to all of the problems that we
face here she's a civil servant doing
her job diligently i'm sure
but you know we know what's going on the
prime minister has admitted what has
gone on it's just this litany of bizarre
excuses what we're focused on as an
opposition is making sure that we've got
the answers to the real challenges
facing the country at the moment not
this ridiculous distraction and the
position that we're in we would we've
got a plan to support families through a
really tough winter with extra help
around gas and electricity bills at a
point which when you know bills are
falling onto mats when you go and do a
shop in the supermarket everything is so
much more expensive and inflation is
rising the government is so mired in
this crisis that there is no plan
they've had months to do this busier
planning parties than providing help for
families that's a difficulty yeah but i
mean look at the furloughs scheme look
at the amount of money that they managed
to put forward there to look after those
hard-working families who were couldn't
go to work so they were supported by the
state in the form of rishi sunak and
that's the first lord of the treasury
yeah well richie zumax got serious
questions to answer about why he's
prepared to prop up this prime minister
who treats the british people with such
contempt of course it's right that when
people are asked to stay at home and
businesses closed that we provided
support we backed the government on that
we called for it we wanted it to happen
however there's no excuse for the four
billion pounds worth of fraud that the
chancellor has overseen nor is there any
excuse for all of those dodgy contracts
uh pp contracts that didn't deliver that
were doled out to friends and donors of
the conservative party that's part of
that whole sorry spectacle that we've
seen in recent months and it's about
bringing decency and integrity back into
public life again if the pm
um if the pm goes doesn't mean that you
guys get into power that they're still
in power the conservative party's still
in power for another two years and
that's why we're absolutely focused on
making sure that we set out
for the next election whenever that
election comes a really strong and
positive vision for the kind of britain
that we believe we can build based on
security respect and prosperity that's
why we've got a plan around cost of
living that's why we've set out a really
clear plan to support our children
who've been a complete afterthought
during this pandemic with a recovery
plan to allow them to make up for all of
that lost learning that they've
experienced as we enter the third year
of disruption for our children we would
put children and young people at the
heart of that recovery for this
government they have never been a
priority um i'm guessing you've got a
front row seat for pmq's later on
looking forward to it
i always look forward to it but i just
it's just week after week and it's
starting to get ridiculous you know the
prime minister turns up same excuses
same old rubbish just he needs to do the
decent thing the british people can see
it we can all see it
time's up but for those conservative
cabinet ministers sat alongside him
today prime minister's questions they've
got to think for themselves
the time has come get on with it you
know this isn't any good anymore